do you think people made too much of
like you and jordan poole yeah even me
honestly obviously i was frustrated you
know how i got hurt you know i sent the
tweet i actually once again my mom came
into play like no deleted then i seen
people start you know trying to talk
trash like oh you deleted you saw at
that time i probably would have got fine
for stuff i said but i had to take that
into consideration so it's all good with
me
so you were frustrated but i feel like
at this point you all have spoken you're
cool yeah even uh when we're about to go
to state like was walking on the court
he asked me was i good you know dapped
me up even some of the other players you
know actually on the side as well that's
what i said that's what it's all about
you know we all at the end of the day
care for each other when everybody
should succeed so i don't think you know
it's too much you know dirty players in
this league to you know go and do you
know anything but after that you know
frustrated in pain not knowing you know
what the results was going to be at the
time my mom you know pretty much was all
over the place after you know the first
incident where you know everybody was
trying to you know bash my teammate not
even knowing that he apologized and
stuff like he didn't mean to do it that
went in to play too so everybody know
i'm one to take up for you know my
people so it's almost like a pressure
cooker there's so much frustration
you're obviously all trying to win and
then everybody's just trying to navigate
you put getting hurt on top of that and
it's a
whole thing